UNRESPONSIVE IN HIS CELL LAST
YEAR, SHE HAS PLEADED NOT GUILTY
GUILTY.
>> WILL YOU VOTE FOR
NANCY PELOSI?
>> I WILL MAKE SURE THE VOTES
ARE HEARD.
YOU WILL FIND OUT THEN.
>> YOU WILL FIND OUT WHEN MY
VOTE IS TALLIED AND AGAIN,
ORGANIZING WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS BEST.
>> Sandra: TWO INCOMING SQUAD
MEMBERS DODGING QUESTIONS ON
WHETHER THEY WILL VOTE FOR
NANCY PELOSI.
SAYING THEY WILL SUPPORT HER,
SHE HAS A MUCH SMALLER MAJORITY
IN THE NEW CONGRESS, SO WHAT
HAPPENS IF THEY DON’T SHOW UP?
UTAH CONGRESSMAN ELECT, MEMBER
OF THE FREEDOM FORCE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
HER?
DOES IT HAPPEN FOR HER?
>> THANK YOU FOR THE INVITE.
FIRST OF ALL, WE THE PEOPLE, WE
STOOD UP AGAINST THE HARD LEFT,
15 SEATS AND NOW WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE SHOULD BE SURPRISED.
LET ME DEFINE WHAT THE HARD LEFT
MEANS, IT CAN BE SAID AND ONE
WORD, IT’S ABOUT POWER.
THESE GUYS LOVE POWER.
UNIFY OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW THEY HAVE IT.
A FREE FALL.
THESE GUYS WILL START GOING AT
EACH OTHER.
I’VE NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME, I’M SO
THANKFUL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE PUT
US IN THE POSITION WHERE NOW WE
CAN HONE IN ON THE STUFF AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SENATE IS HELD ONTO, WE WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO REALLY EDUCATE
OURSELVES, TO REALLY SPEAK LARGE
LARGE.
>> Sandra: I WILL ASK YOU
ABOUT GEORGE, BUT FIRST, THESE
DEMOCRATS ALREADY IN CONGRESS,
THESE NAMES SAID THEY WILL NOT
BACK NANCY PELOSI.
JARED GOLDEN HAS GONE ON THE
RECORD.
AND HERE IS KENTUCKY DEMOCRAT,
HE THINKS THE MARGIN COULD BE SO
TIGHT THAT McCARTHY MIGHT WIN
ELECTION FOR HOUSE SPEAKER.
HERE IT IS.
LET’S SAY THEORETICALLY WE ARE
PEOPLE OUT, THEY COULD ELECT
KEVIN McCARTHY.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> IT’S INTERESTING.
IT’S THE WAY OUR CONSTITUTION
WAS SET UP.
IT’S SO DEEP AND AGAIN, I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT HOW IT CAN BE WHAT
WE ARE UP AGAINST.
I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A PART
OF THAT PROCESS.
I CAN’T WAIT TO BE THERE TO
REALLY DO MY PART.
>> Sandra: MEANWHILE,
BERNIE SANDERS WAS ASKED ABOUT
WHAT HE HAD SEEN SO FAR, AS FAR
AS JOE BIDEN’S CABINET.
HE HAS CHOSEN TO BE ON HIS TEAM
AND LEAVE THE COUNTRY AND HE
SAID THAT SPIRIT I WILL GET YOUR
RESPONSE.
>> THE MOVEMENT IS 35 OR 40% OF
THE DEMOCRATIC COALITION.
AND I BELIEVE THE PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT DESERVES SEATS IN THE
CABINET THAT HAVE NOT YET
HAPPENED.
I DON’T KNOW HIM VERY WELL, BUT
I THINK WE HAVE A STRONG
PROGRESSIVE.
>> Sandra: LAYING ON FIXED
PRESSURE ON THAT ADMINISTRATION.
TO HAVE MORE PROGRESSIVES THAN
HIS CABINET.
DO YOU SEE HIM CAVING TO THOSE
DEMANDS?
>> I DO.
WHEN YOU SAY PROGRESSIVE, THAT
MEAN SOCIALIST.
UNDERSTAND THAT.
I HAVE NO DOUBT.
FOR ANYBODY WHO IS LISTEN TO
JOE BIDEN, HE’S NOT THE GUY THAT
PEOPLE REMEMBER HIM 40 YEARS
AGO.
HE’S A SHELL.
BEING THAT KIND OF LEADER IF WE
WILL CALL HIM THAT, THE
PROGRESSIVES WILL HAVE MORE OF
AN IMPACT.
THAT IS WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU AGAIN, WE HAVE A TEAM
COMING IN THAT CAN TRULY STAND
UP AGAINST THE SPIRIT
>> Sandra: YOU MENTIONED, ALL
EYES WILL BE ON GEORGIA
BEGINNING JANUARY AND IT WILL
MATTER FOR YOUR PARTY AND FOR